مساء الخير اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه
الساعه نستمر من خلالها في تغديتنا الى
الحدث الابرز هذا اليوم احدث سودا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يوم دام اذا في السودان اشتباكات واتهامات
ايضا متبادله بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في اخر التطورات اكد رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان للعربيه ان من
وصفهم بمتمردي الدعم السريع سعوا للسيطره
على مقرات الجيش والمناطق الحيويه فجرا
البرهان اتهم قوات الدعم السريع بالتخطيطي
لتنفيذ الاغتيالات والبران كد ايضا ان
خيار الجيش الوحيد هو التصدي لما الطامع
المتمردين في السلطه
من مدينه مروي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي
او سنتابع معكم يعني
تناول كل التطورات المتعلقه بما يجري الان
في السودان نذكر باهم ردود الافعال
العربيه والدوليه حيث اعربت الخارجيه
السعوديه عن قلق المملكه من حاله التصعيد
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في السودان
السعوديه دعت المكون العسكري وجميع
القيادات السياسيه في السودان الى
التغليبي لغه الحوار وضبط النفس والتوصل
لاعلان سياسي يتحقق بموجبه الاستقرار من
جهتها اعربت مصر عن بالغ قلقها ازاء
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في السودان ودعت كافه الاطراف
السودانيه الى ممارسه اقصى درجات ضبط
النفس حمايه لارواح ومقدرات الشعب
السوداني واعلاء للمصالح العليا للوطن
ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده في
السودان دعا الى وقف فوري للاشتباكات
والنزاع بين الجيش والدعم السريع وقال
فولكررت في بيان انه يدين القتال الحرير
في السودان داعيا الى الهدوء واكد انه
تواصل مع كلا الطرفين لضمان سلامه
السوداني والتجنب العنف السفاره
البريطانيه من جانبها ايضا دعت رعايا في
السودان الى البقاء في اماكن مغلقه وقالت
انها تراقب الموقف عن كتب بعدما اعلنت
قوات الدعم السريع انها سيطرت على القصر
الرئاسي ومواقع اخرى
ينضم اليها في الاستوديو الصحفي احمد
القرشي اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ احمد كيف
تراقب اولا وتقيم ما يجري الان في الخرطوم
من مواجهات في اكثر من منطقه من العاصمه
في مروي ايضا الى اين تتجه الامور في
السود
طبعا الوضع يمكن ان نحدد انه معقد لانه في
ساعات الاولى للصراع بذره او
اصوله بدات منذ العام 2018 عندما يعني
بدات
الثوره او ثوره ديسمبر في الانتصار
ابريل 2019 كان هناك صراع واضح جدا جدا
بين القوه الدعم السريع اللي هي تاسست في
العام 2013 او ما قبله كمجموعه غير نظاميه
هذه المجموعه نمت وادت ادوار متعدده
فعندما دخلنا الى العام 2018 كان لديها
تصورات سياسيه وكان لديها
نظره مختلفه الى اداره شؤون الدوله فعندما
انتصرت
اراده السودانيين في ابريل 2019
اصبحت هنالك مشكله جديده تسمى الدعم
السريع الدعم السريع يعتقد انه يعني قوه
جزء اصيل من
القوه التي نشات في الفتره بتاعت الصراع
في دارفور وانه تحول الى قوه شبه اتحاديه
من قوى محصوره على الصراع في دارفور الى
قوه حرس لكنها لم تكن في يوم من الايام
قوه منظمه عندها يعني مرجعيه
تستطيع انه تستند اليها وتستطيع محاسبتها
لانها قامت اصلا على فكره المكون الجهوي
القبلي اللي هو الرزيقات ما يسمى
بالرزيقات ما يسمى بالرزقات دي مش يعني
تقليلا من شان الرزيقات لكن
هنالك
بطن في هذا في هذه القبيله
حركه الدعم السريع قوات الدعم السريع
وسميت اسماء كثيره من هذا البطن وداخل هذا
البطن من عشيره محدده لذلك عندما جاءت
ونمت واصبح لها نشاطات اقتصاديه قويه
واصبح لها يعني طموح سياسي قوي
تضاربت المصالح فنجد منذ العام 2019
موجوده في كل مكان خالد يعني نحن لما
نتكلم عن التلفزيون هنالك في يعني
اشتباكات في المحيط
قوه الدعم السريع سمح لها هذه الاشياء
الغريبه انه قوه يعني او يعني اليوم الجيش
بيقول انها ماليشيا وهذا كان التصنيف
المعروف بالنسبه الى
موجوده في كل ما قال رئيسي حتى في القصر
الرئاسي هذه القوه موجوده منزل عام 2019
هذه القوه نمت بسرعه كبيره جدا جدا منذ
العام 2019 اللي هو بعد انتصار الثوره وفي
وجود البرهان نمت من خلال تجاره الذهب
يعني تجاره منظمه عبر الشركات لانه كما
قلنا انه هو اساس اساس عائلي اساس عنصري
اساس جهوي فلذلك كانت استثمر هذه الاموال
بالاضافه الى اموال الدوله في بناء قوته
في بناء قوتها من خلال انها تكون قوه قوه
سريعه لكنها حاسمه لذلك كانت تاتي باسلحه
من تشاد وتاتي باسلحتها يعني تصدر اليها
الاسلحه الى تشاد وتصدر اليها الاسلحه الى
افريقيا الوسطى وتهربها الى مناطق في
دارفور يتدرب عليها من خلال مدربين ياتوا
اليها من انحاء كثيره لذلك نحن لمن عندما
نتحدث الان منحدث عن حوالي 50 الف مقاتل
في الخرطوم وحده نحن بنعرف
خالد انه الخرطوم تشمل يعني لما نتحدث عن
الخرطوم تشمل الخرطوم ام درمان الخرطوم
بحري وفي ثلاثه مناطق هذه هنالك المناطق
ما يسمى بالمناطق العسكريه الاكبر للجيش
السوداني
هنالك
القاعده الجويه الابرز اللي هي قاعده
وادي سيدنا هذه القوات قوات الدعم السريع
ما حوالي 60 الف او خمسين الف انتشروا في
مناطق كثيره بقبول الجيش ودون رفض في
المناطق الحيويه لذلك عندما يقول لك انه
القصر الرئاسي نعم هم كانوا موجودين لكن
ما اود الاشاره اليه هو بقوه انه الان في
الخرطوم
راي العين يعني الدبابات والقوات المسلحه
السودانيه بتنتج كل مكان لانه كما قلنا بل
خالد نحن نصحنا انه وكثيرا نصحنا انه
الجيش السوداني والقوات المسلحه السودانيه
نعم هنالك في طموح
مشروع لقوى
قبليه وقوه جهاويه وقوه سياسيه في انه تصل
الى السلطه وعندها مشروعيه في انها تضع
يعني ما
ترفض او
تنتقد في القوى العسكريه الموجوده خصوصا
في الجيش السوداني لا باس في ذلك لكن
قلنا وقال كثيرون وبحكمه وبصبر ان الوصول
الى الجيش السوداني انما هو منطقه الهاويه
التي لن يعود منها السودان السودان كيف
اذا نجح نجح الامر بطريقته هذا يمكن
الفوضى تصور هذه المعركه يعني اليوم يبدو
ان المعركه الرئيسيه هي في الخرطوم من
يستطيع السيطره على الخرطوم يمكن ان يسيطر
على القرار السياسي القرار العسكري
وكافه التفاصيل ربما القرار السيادي في
السودان لكن من يمكن ان يحسم المعركه في
مدينه الخرطوم بها كثافه سكانيه عاليه حتى
الفروقات ربما الاليه المتعلقه بتسليح
الذي قد يتفوق فيه الجيش نوعيا قد تدزول
كل هذه الفوارق في هذه المنطقه كما قلت
هذه
كثافه سكانيه يعني نحن عندما نتحدث عن
مروي مروي في شمال السودان منطقه يعني
تنتمي الى قبائل الشقيقيه اللي هي يعني
انا لا اريد ان احدث اسم القبيله لكن هذه
مناطق انتماء معروف حتى الجيش السوداني
منذ يعني عندما نتحدث عن
الخياله وعندما نتحدث عن
العساكر السودانيين الذين خدموا في تركيا
وخدموا الجيش الانجليزي هم من هذه المناطق
الكثافه السكانيه والسكان كان لهم دور
كبير جدا بالامس وقبل الامس وكذا في حسم
وجود الدعم السريع في منطقه مروي انه
رفضوا وجوده وهذا لم يكن رفضا يعني
سياسيا لكن هو رفضا اجتماعيا لذلك تحدثنا
عن انه كيف البيئه التي يمكن ان تلفظ اي
نوع من
التحرك اللي فيه اي سمات عنصريه هذه
البيئه بيئه قويه جدا جدا خصوصا في شمال
السودان انه انت بتاتي بعسكر بتاتي بعقليه
بتاتي
يعني عسكره
منطلقه من اثنيه محدده ومنطلقه من مكون
عرق محدد في السودان ليست مساله قوميه انت
بتتحدث عن الدعم
ون له يعني
انهم يعني وجدوا انفسهم في خضام صراع
عرقي قبلي لذلك هذا التشكل اليوم هذا
الشعب السوداني بمكونات المختلفه في
المختلفه نحن لا ننسى خالد مناطق
استراتيجيه اخرى غير الخرطوم هنالك بورس
سودان الميناء الرئيسي يعني في سواتن
المنطقه الرئيسيه موجوده فيها ايضا قوات
الدعم السريع كيف يمكن ان يتصرف الجيش
وبحاضنه شعبيه لان الجيش السوداني يعني
يجب ان نثبت انه مؤسسه قوميه وتائه على
اسس منذ عام 1925 وقبلها كقوه الدفاع
السودان وحتى يومنا هذا نعم حصل فيها
تشوهات كثيره وحصلت فيها اشياء كثيره لكن
لا زال هو ذلك الموئي البتاع السودانيين
بمختلف
عرقيات لذلك اليوم
موقف الناس هو برضو مهم جدا جدا في حسم
الصراع اللي بيحصل ده ياخذ وجهه نظر ايضا
ضيفي الذي ينضم الينا الان من الخرطوم
المحلل الاستراتيجي الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين سيد فتح الرحمن اهلا وسهلا بك معي
في هذه التغطيه لا صوت الان يعلو فوق صوت
المعركه هل وصلت الامور ما نشاهده الان من
مواجهات خاصه في الخرطوم مع انتشار دبابات
تحليق طائرات ارتفاع سحب الدخان
السله اللهب ايضا المواجهات في اكثر من
منطقه هل يمكن لاي طرف ان يحسم المعركه
خلال الايام قليله كما قال حميتي في
تصريحه الاخير
سيد فتح الرحمن
في اطار تغطتنا ايضا الان من الخرطوم ينضم
الينا الكاتب الصحفي عمرو شعبان سيد عمرو
اهلا وسهلا بك تاتي السؤال اطرحه عليك
يعني هل يمكن حسم المعركه لاي طرف خلال
ايام كما قال
قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
في الخرطوم تحديدا
حقيقه هذا الامر يبدو
صعبه صعبه الاجابه عليه في ظل المعلومات
تقريبا
موقع موقع العسكري في افريقيا
اورد قبل خمسه ايام ان الجيش السوداني هو
السابع افريقيا اذ يمتلك 109
عسكري ناشط او جندي ناشط فيما يقال وفيما
يمتلك 150 الجندي بالاحتياطي في المقابل
على مستوى التعداد موازين القوى بالتعداد
مقابل الدعم السريع
انواع التسليح سلاح الطيران ومدرعات
بالتاكيد شكلوا فرقا منذ لحظه الاولى خلال
هذه الساعات الاولى خلال هذا اليوم لكن
دعنا نقول ان سياسيا كلا الطرفين خسران
منذ اللحظه الذي طلقت فيه الطلقه الاولى
الطلقه الاولى تعني ان الفوضى في طريقها
الى البلاد سياسيا تم تجاوز كل الوسطات
الدوليه والاقليميه بل والمتعاطفين معهم
من القوى السياسيه والباحثين عن تسويه سي
اسيه جاريه هؤلاء كلهم تم فقدهم من اللحظه
اللحظه التي انطلقت فيها الرصاصه غضن
النظر عن من الذي ابتدر هذا
الصراع او هذه الحرب عموما يمكن حسم هذا
الامر
لا يوجد في مثل هذه الحروب داخل المدن امن
هو منتصر او فايز ولكن يوجد نوع من الضغوط
يمكن ان تمارس الطرفين في اطلاق النار ومن
ثم اجلاسهما والضغط عليهما للجلوس حول
مائه التفاوض ربما ذلك يقلل من حجم
الاضرار التي تقع على الشعب السوداني
حاليا طب نتابع معكم الان ايضا هذه الصور
التي وصلتنا قبل قليل يتواجد قوات الدعم
السريع لاحد مقرات الجيش السوداني في
العاصمه الخرطوم كما نتابع
طيب اسمع منك تعليق استاذ احمد القرشي حول
ما تشاهد
ايضا كما ذكرت خالد انه
كانت هنالك مساله غريبه انه الدعم السريع
موجود في كل مكان موجود فيه الجيش
السوداني يعني اصلا
المقارنه اللي في الخرطوم هم تركوه جنود
الدعم وانا انا دلوقتي المتحدث الرسمي
باسم
الجيش السوداني بيقول انه في مناطق عديده
يعني ان هم
تركوا
يعني اسلحتهم وتركوا
الياتهم وذهبوا ودون القوات المسلحه وجهت
جنودا
جنود الدعم السريع غير المسلحين يجب عدم
التصدي لهم انه فقط الاجراءات القانونيه
اللي بتتخذ لانها زي ما قلت لك انه يعني
الدعم السريع لا يعرف انه باي قانون يحاسب
من 2017 تم يعني
خلق ارتباط مع القوات المسلحه وقبلها كان
مرتبط بجهاز الامن وبعدها كان مرتبطه
بالرئيس المخلوع السابق عمر البشير فعندما
جاء
جاءت الثوره بعد العامه 2019
وصيد الفريق
عبد الرحمن
يعني صيد الفريق
البرهان
واخيرا كان صرح السيد الفريق
العطا انه نزلت الدعم السريع والقانون
بحيث انه يحكم
تبعيتها ويحكم
اليتا انتهت هذه المساله
وستناقش في اطار ما يسمى بالاتفاق الاطاري
انه يدمج الدعم السريعه الدعم السريع
اخيرا بدا يتحدث مش عن الدمج بدا يتحدث عن
التفاهم مع القوات المسلحه كقوه موازيه
كقوه موازيه كقوه رديئه كقوه تتساوى في
الحقوق والواجبات فانه لازم يجلسوا مع بعض
ويفكروا انه كيف يخلقوا قوه جديده وده هذا
هو واحد سبب من الاذباب اللي جعل الامر
يتص اعد انه لا يوجد حل يعني طيب خلينا
نريد يعني نستعرض معكم كذلك هذا الفيديو
الان يظهر في احد اضبط في قوات الدعم
السريع داخل الجيش يعلن انسحابه من الدعم
السريع وعودته الى الجيش
قوات المسلحه الدعم السريع تقدمت بطلب
الهاندي من قوات الدعم السريع عدد من
المرات ولكن طلبي لم يجد القبول من قياده
الدعم السريع بناء على ذلك ولن عن انسلاخ
عن قوات الدعم السريع من انضمام للقوات
المسلحه كما جميع طبعات القوات المسلحه
المنتدبين على قوات الدعم السريع
التوجه فورا الى وحدات القوات المسلحه
وانهاء انتدابهم
النقيب مهندس عثمان في عمر الخامس عشر من
ابريل 2023
للمتابعه من الخرطوم ينضم الينا السيد فتح
الرحمن محي الدين المحل الاستراتيجي سيد
فتح الرحمن الان الاخبار العاجله تقول ان
قوات الدعم السريع سيطرت على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
عندما يتم الحديث ربما عن الاسلحه هناك
فروقات فنيه كبيره على مستوى الاليات على
مستوى القوات على مستوى العدد على مستوى
التجهيزات العسكريه لكن فيما يبدو ان قوات
الدعم السريع من خلال قدرتها على التحرك
السريعه تستطيع ربما قلب هذه الحاله
وربما من صالحها يعني حاله التوازن من
صالحها في الخرطوم الى اي مدى يمكن ان
يكون لذلك
عامل حسم لهذه المعركه في وهي المعركه
الرئيسيه في العاصمه السودانيه
لصالح القوات المسلحه دون منازع يعني
بالتاكيد صحيح يعني كونه دخلوا من الازاحه
هذا امر طبيعي لانهم اصلا متواجدين في يوم
متواجدين
يعني هذا ليس بالامر الجديد وتدعم السريع
القوات المسلحه كانت تتعامل معها
باعتبارها جزء من القوات المسلحه تنفتح في
معظم المرافق الاستراتيجيه داخل الخرطوم
وكانت تتعامل معها باعتبارها ايه جزء منها
وليست
شيء غريب منها لكن للاسف
خلال نتيجه المسلحه وليس الجسم مساند لابو
المسلحه وبدات تتعامل بانها يمكن ان تتحرى
وتنفتح دون المسلحه وهي راسها وهذا ما
بالتاكيد قياده القوات المسلحه وطالبهم
مرارا وتكرارا بضروره عدم التحرك والضروره
بعدم الانفتاح الا بالتنسيق المجتمعه
لكنهم اصرروا
واجاهدنا كيف فتح منطقه
يحدثهم عن ان يبلغوا ان
تمرد على لكن كيف ستستطيع القوات المسلحه
والجيش حسب هذه المعركه امام هذا الانتشار
الكبير لقوات الدعم السوق السريع في
السودان
رغم التمرد عليها اكثر من 72 ساعه الا
انها ظلت تميت حبال الصبر على امل ان
ينتهي هذا التمرد بالتي هي احسن دون ان
ندخل في صراع مسلح ولكنهم اليوم
واطلبوا زي يقولون الطلقه الاولى وبالتالي
انفجرت الاوضاع الان لا يمكن ان تتوقف هذه
المعارك الا اذا ما تراجعت وهات الدعم
السريعا تمردها وانت تدعم سريع وانا لا
اقول كل الدعم السريع يعني جزء كبير
الانحاز الى القوات المسلحه وبدات تعمل مع
الرؤيه المسلحه لكن الذين يعملوا تحت
قياده
الفريق الاول محمد حمدان هم الذين الان
يجب اما ان يتراجعوا من التمرد الذي هم
فيهم واما ان يتم حجمهم العسكريه
يعني
ماذا تقصد بالقوه العسكريه يعني استخدام
الطائرات استخدام دبابات تسلموا او يتراجع
من تمر يا استاذ اي دوله في الدنيا لا
يمكن ان تسمح القوات المسلحه لقوه مسلحه
متمرس في المدن هذا غير مضبوط طبعا
وبالتالي يجب على القوات المسلحه ان
تتعامل بحسب
عن عن كثافه مدنيه عاليه تحيط بكل المراكز
بكل الجهات الحكوميه السياديه والسياسيه
والعسكريه وغيرها هذا كبير وخطر كارثي
ربما على على
نحن نتحدث عن امن وطني
نتحدث عن اني لا اريد خسائر واريد الامور
ان تنجلي بالتي هي احسن
[موسيقى]
ويضيع السودان هذا كلام غير مقبول الان
نحن في مرحله مفصليه يجب علينا ان نحافظ
على الامن والاستقرار من خلال القوات
المسلحه وليست من خلال اي اسم اخر
وبالتالي واجب على القوات المسلحه ان تفرض
سيطرتها على قوات الدعم السريعه المتمرده
عليها يجب على غوات الدعم سريعا تتراجع من
هذا التمرد انا اؤكد لك القوات المسلحه
حريصه على ان يتوقف القتال الان قبل الغد
لكن لا يمكن ان يتوقف وهنالك قوه متمرده
تشهر السلاح في وجه الدوله هذا كلام غير
مقبول يجب هذه القوه ان تتراجع من تمرده
وتضع سلاحها ثم بعد ذلك الناس تسجد كيف
تعالج الازمه التي نشات هذه لكن بخلاف ذلك
انا لا اعتقد بسهوله
وهذا ما كنا نخشاه للاسف يعني طيله الفتن
كنا نحذر الاخوه المدنيين ابعدوا عن الله
النظاميه وابعدوا عن الجيش واللعب مع
القوات المسلحه خطير جدا وتمن غالي جدا
لكنه كانوا يستهترون ويقولون اين هي
القوات المسلحه ليش ما عندنا جيش ويقولوا
هذا الكلام التافه والان وجب على القوات
المسلحه عن تلقن كل عميل الدرس ويجب ان
المسلحات
السودان وما هو مصير الاتفاقيه السياسيه
ايضا والتحمل التحول الديمقراطي الذي
يعني وصل الى مراحل متقدمه في السودان
هو اصلا من البدايه وصل المراحل المتقدمه
لكنه كان اعرج كان منقوص يعني هو اتفاق
كان ماضي معي فئه قليله من الشعب السوداني
هنالك قوه دوريه كثيره جدا وكانت رافضه
للاتفاق الايطالي انا اعتقد انه بعد ان
ينجلي هذا الموقف ستكون يعني القوات
المسلحه حريصه تخرج من المشهد السياسي
حريصه تسلم السلطه المدنيين لكن ان تجلس
فيما بينها ان تتوافق بعد ان نبعد العملاء
بعدها
الى ان يخرجوا الدعم السريع من القوات بعد
ان نبعد الذين سعوا الى تفكيك القوات
المسلحه تجب هؤلاء
ويعرفهم الجميع ويجب ان يحاسبوا على
جرائهم
الانتقاليه للامام والقوات المسلحه تتفرغ
الى واجباتها الاساسيه
وترمي افسدته عليها
استاذ احمد هل يمكن بالفعل الوصول او حسن
هذه المعركه الوصول الى حل ام انه سيظل
السودان كما عرفناه على مدى التاريخ
رهينا في استقراره للمتنافسين دائما
العسكريين على السلطه وسدت الحكم هذه
المعركه معركه يعني او هذا الربشن اللي
حصل
هذا
الصراع الذي نشا صباح اليوم
كما ذكر سعاده الفريق
يعني
واضح انه هذه مساله عمرها اكثر من اربع
سنوات
وجاء يعني مرت عبر يعني بؤر
ومنحنيات كثيره ووصلت الى هذه النقطه
فنحن
الامنيات في العمل السياسي والعمل الصحفي
دائما مرتبطه بالواقع نحن نقول ان الجيش
السوداني مؤسسه عريقه مؤسسه عندها يعني
ما يدعنا انه نقول انه كمؤسسه دوله يمكنها
ان تحسم هذا الصراع في يوم في يوم من في
ثلاثه ايام لكن
الخسائر التي ستنجم عن هذا هذا الحسم
ستكون كبيره جدا جدا وعندما نعود الى جاده
الطريق وعندما نتحدث
نتكلم سياسه انه هذه المشكله التي نجمت او
ظهرت اليوم هي نتائج لضعف ضعف كبير الم
بالعمليه السياسيه
وفرص اتيحت
لدعم السريع كمجموعه انها تقوي نفسها انها
تنتشر في كل مكان زي ما قال سعاده الفريق
من الذي سمح لها بذلك كان دوره محدود جدا
جدا اصبح دور واسع لذلك اي خسائر بتحدث
اليوم واي يعني ضياع لموارد ارواح كريمه
بيكون السبب فيه ما يتولى هذا البلد
وزمامه في المرحله السابقه ثانيا انا اقول
وبكل قوه انه ايضا عدم الثقه اللي كانت
مبنيه بين المدنيين وبين الجيش
والمكونات الاخرى هو الذي قادنا الى هذه
اللحظه فيجب فيجب انه يكون هنالك في وضوح
انه لن ترتد العمليه السياسيه ولن يرتد
التحول المدني حتى انه ما الوضع اللي نحن
فيه ما يتعقد بمعنى انه القوه السياسيه
الموجوده لابد انه نعطيها ضمانات نقول نعم
رغم هذا الذي يحدث الجيش كما الوثيقه
الموجوده استمر الوضع لا منتصر في هذه
المعركه حتى لكن هنالك تقود او يفوز على
رماد ايوه هنالك هنالك طرفان الطرف نحن
نقف مع المؤسسه يعني الشعب اول الذين
يتحدثون الان عن الموقف انت تقف مع
المؤسسه نقف مع اي دوله مؤسسه الدوله
الجيش السوداني العظيمه العريق اللي هو
حتى الشعب السوداني
على الدعم السريع نحن نتحدث عن اذا كانت
هنالك في مواقف قيادات الجيش في وقت معين
اختلف مع اي حد ابدا انه الجيش السوداني
كحامي وامين كجزء من مؤسسات الدوله انت لا
تناصره لانه حزب او لانه فئه معين او كيان
او نحن نناصره لانه نحن نناصر الدوله
نناصر الاستقرار اذا كان
هكذا الامر بالنسبه للسياسيين يتخذون هذا
الموقف حينا يسارا ويمنى لذلك انا قلت
لسعاده الفريق انه الجيش لابد ان يكون
مؤسس الدوله لابد ان يصر انه هو مؤسس حتى
انه يجد التاييد ويجد القبول السياسي نحن
في هذه اللحظه نريد انه كل الفئات وكل
القوى السياسيه الشعب السوداني يقف مع
جيشه لماذا حتى نقلل الخسائر حتى له ما
نذهب الى اتون حرب اهليه السودان بلد كبير
بلد فقير بلد بيعاني من خلل هيكلي اي
انزلاق من هذا القبيل
سيطيل امد المعاناه الانسانيه في هذه
المنطقه العزيزه من افريقيا ومن الوطن
العربي فلذلك نحن نقول لا يجب انه الجيش
يتعالى ويجب ان الجيش يكون عنده السمو
والصبر والحكمه ويقول نعم موقفنا انه ان
تذهب هذه العمليه الى منتهاها
التجيش السياسي الذي حدث من بعض القوه مع
الدعم السريع واتهاماته لبعض قوى الحريه
والتغيير بانها حليفه لدعم السريع هذا لا
يغني ولا يثمن
الاساسي لا بد ان تكون هي مؤسسه الدوله
وتقول انها مع الانتقال الديمقراطي وهي مع
الانتقال المدني وستحميه وستعزز وتدعمه هل
هناك اي طرف سيد فتح الرحمن محي الدين من
داخل السودان او من الاطراف الدوليه يمكن
بالفعل ان يلعب دورا الان مهما ومؤثرا في
ايقاف هذه الاشتباكات والمواجهات التي
تنذر
كارثه خطيره على مستقبل السودان
في تخفيف هذا التوتر الاقتراح يمكن ايضا
بعض القوى الاقليميه والدوليه ان تتدخل
لاضافه الاستراحه لكن الشيء المهم الذي
يجب ان يؤمن عليه الجميع وكل الوسطاء يجب
ان يهمل عليه المتعارض عليه في كل العالم
يا استاذ لما يكون هنالك قوات مسلحه
للدوله وهنالك اسم يتمرد عليها يجب ان يتم
حجم هذا التمرد او اي يتراجع الجسم
المتمرد عن تمرد فالان جزء
المسلحه يجب عليهما ان يعود من هذا التمرد
لكي تقي في هذه المعرفه
القوات التدخلات التي نرجوها نرجوها ان
تكون مع فائده الدعم السريع الذي سميناه
قبل قليل
بانه
على البرهان ويجب
يحاكم البرهان هذا يؤكد انه هو مستمر في
تمرده مستمر في تعانته وهذا لن يحل الازمه
حل الازمه ياتي بتراجعه الوسطاء ان ارادوا
ان يتدخلوا في هذا الامر يتدخلوا في
الحديث مع الفريق الحميدي في ان يتراجع من
هذا الموقف وان يستمع الى صوت العقل
والحكمه
ويحزن الدماء وكفى خسائر حتى الان
وتحل الازمه هكذا لكن انا لا اعتقد ان
ازمه تظهر وهذه المعركه انا لا اعتقد انها
ستطول يا استاذ يعني المعركه هذه انا
اعتقد انها ستحسم خلال ساعات خلال ساعات
يعني
لن تطول ان شاء الله
كبير جدا من الق
القوات المسلحه والقوات المسلحه ترحب به
وترحب بكل من
يرفض القتال ضدها
زياده عن اللازم سيد فتحي الرحمن
ان شاء الله هذا هو الواقع ان شاء الله
شكرا جزيلا لك المحل الاستراتيجي الفريق
فتح الرحمن محي الدين هل تتفق مع راي
السيد فتح الرحمن معركه خلال ساعات
ربما هو طبعا عسكري وقريب من
دائره القرار في تسمح لي فقط استاذ احمد
اعتذر لمقاطعتك اريد فقط ان اذهب الى
الخرطوم الى مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
سالم مرحبا بك كيف تجريه وتتطور الاوضاع
الان في الخرطوم سالم
المشاهدين
الان سيطرت القوات الدعم السيئه على مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون بالكامل حتى الدبابات
التي كانت تحرس مبنى للدعوه التلفزيون
تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم السريعه الان
تم تدمير استديو بالكامل في داخل مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في ام درمان في هذه
في هذه اللحظات القوات الدعم السريع
بالكامل تحكم سيطرتها على مبنى على الهيئه
العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون نحن هنا في
بحري ما زال ذوي اطلاق الرصاص وكذلك
المضادات مضادات الطيران والطيران بين
الفينا والاخرى
يشم بعض الغارات على منطقه بحرين
المواطنين هنا في جعر
رهيب الذعر سببه انهم اصبحوا في حيره من
امرهم هل يدخلون الى المنازل يخرجون الى
الخارج في المنازل هناك تصدعات هناك بيوت
الان مع هذه المضادات القويه
والطيران الذي ايضا بدا في
ضرب ايضا في هذه المناظر تصدعات سقوط
اجزاء من الاسقف غير المنازل فنزلوا الى
الطابق الارضيه في المنازل وهم متواجدين
الان في دور كامل بالنسبه للاحصائيات
والارقام للاصابات هنا في المستشفى الدولي
في بحري عدد الاصابات الان 26 اصابه
حالتين وفاه وهناك اصابات خطيره واصابه
للاطفال كل هذه الاصابات المدنيين بالكامل
لجنه الطباله المركزيه تتحدث على انها لا
تستطيع ان توصل المساعدات لهؤلاء
المصابين في المستشفيات وخصوص منهم مستشهد
الدولي هنا في بحري بعد ان وقفنا على حجم
الاضرار التي تعرضوا لها في زياره لنا في
المستشفى بدات ايضا لعيبه الناريه واطلاق
الرصاص وكذلك
القنابل دفعهم الى الدخول للمستشفى مره
اخرى واغلاق المستشفى بالكامل في هذه
اللحظات
شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه
من الخطوط استاذ احمد اولا اريد تعليقا
منك على الدلالات سيطره قوات الدعم السريع
التامه حتى الان على مبنى الاذاعه لم
تسيطر حقيقه زي ما قلنا ان هي موجوده فيه
يعني اصلا هذه القوات وهذا يعني
هناك
هذا الموقع يقع على النيل الازرق يعني على
بعد
اربعه نحو اربع كلمات ونصف من منطقه مقرن
النيلين هذه هذه الدبابات موجوده منزل
الستينات والسبعينات يعني في اماكن لكن
قوات الدعم السريع كما قلنا في هذه يعني
المناطق الحيويه زي الايداع والتلفزيون
خلقت لها زيت حاميات موجوده في كل مكان
ستسيطر على كل الجهات لا لا ما هي سيطره
ايوه السيطره سيط محدوده بمعنى ايش بمعنى
انه انت اليوم المكان هذا الموجوده فيه
والاذاعه والتلفزيون منطقه سكنيه مع الاسف
الشديد يعني هي منطقه تطورت الى سكنيه
لانه منطقه الملازمين تسمى منطقه
الملازمين اللي هي وراء على طول منزل
الصيد الصادق المهدي رحمه الله عليه
الامام هذا المكان
الصراع فيه بسيط يعني مش
عالي يعني مش الاهتمام
بالاذاعه والتلفزيون دلوقتي متوقف يعني
اوى التليفزيون
تحديدا متوقف لكن الاذاعات المرتبطه
بالهيئه القوميه للاذاعه والتلفزيون موزع
في اماكن كثيره المهم في الموضوع انه يعني
هذه ليست مشكله كبيره لانه اصلا كانوا
موجودين هناك وربما الجيش يعني عنده كما
قلنا في ام درمان عنده مناطق عده حيويه
اللي هي منها وادي سيدنا منها المنطقه
العسكريه بتاعت ام درمان نفسها منطقه
كبيره جدا جدا وضخمه ما قالوا الفريق فتح
الرحمن انه
انا خلال ساعات سيتم السيطره على الموقع
ربما هو يعني هو عسكري يستطيع ان من خلال
يعني حسابه لكن انا سياسي وكاعلامي وراء
انه هذه لا يبرا منها يعني مش المها فقط
انما تداعياتها لانه انت اليوم قبل
التداعيات هل هي بالفعل ساعه ام ستاخذ
ايام مساله متصله خالد كما قلنا بطبيعه
تكوين
الدعم السريع اليوم الدعم السريع حتى لو
افترضنا وانا استبعد هذا الاحتمال يعني
99. انه ينتصر في هذه المعركه اذا
ايضا التداعيات العراقيه والتداعيات
الاجتماعيه والتداعيات السياسيه
والتداعيات التي هتكون خطيره جدا جدا لذلك
حتى لو حسم هذا المعركه في 4 يعني ساعات
ثمانيه ساعات في عشر ساعات نهايته حتكون
يعني ناس باسلحتها تختبئ وحتبدا يعني لا
نعرف بدقه مدى
الحجم او تداعياتها وطبيعه على كل
المستويات سياسيا واجتماعي ربما ياخذون
وجهه وجهه نظر الكاتب الصحفي عمر شعبان
اولا هل تتفق بان المعركه يمكن ان تاخذ
ساعات قليله بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني
كما ذهب الى ذلك سيد فتح الرحمن ام انه
المعركه ستطول في ضوء التطورات ما نشهده
الان ايضا من اخبار عاجله حول سيطره يعني
من قبل السريع مثلا على مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون انتشار ايضا المعارك
والاشتباكات في اكثر مكان في العاصمه
السوداني سيد عمرو
يتوقف على مدى تحقيق الهدف الذي قامت من
اجله المعركه نفسها هل الم يدرك حميتني
مثلا انه اذا دخل في مواجهه مع الجيش
سننتهي سيتيم الانتصار عليه وسحقه خلال
ثلاثه ايام او ثلاث ساعات بالتاكيد هنالك
فرديه غائبه لا ندركها ايضا الهدف الحقيقي
هو كما قلت اشرت
كما صرت اعرف انه سابقا ان الهدف الحقيقي
هو صرف الانظار ونقل العالم على مستوى
الدولي والاقليمي والمحلي من البحث عن
الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي والحكمه
المدني في السودان الى البحث عن امان في
ظل حاله الهلع التي يعيشها السودانيين
حاليا في ظل وجود اتصالات تعمل انترنت
ينقل في السوشيال ميديا الماسي الماسله في
الشارع عمليه الاشتباكات التي تدور داخل
العاصمه الخرطومه التي كانت من امن
العواصم في العالم عموما تحقيق هذا الهدف
ربما يكون نجاح وبالتالي تم تجاوز ما يسمى
بالعمليه السياسيه او تم ركنها في مؤخره
الذاكره كل المعانين بالملف لصالح البحث
عن امان وتوقف صوت الرصاص في الخرطوم دعنا
نبحث ايضا عن الفرضيه التي اشرت لك اليها
اذا كان
لا قبل له بالجيش فلماذا
قام بهذه الخطوه كما قلت انفا ان سيناريو
الجمج الذي وافق عليهما في داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه او داخل الجيش ارتبط زمانيا
البروده التي دخلت في منطقه او البائع
الاول دائره المشتعله في اليمن في ظل
التهدئه التي حشادها ملف الهجره غير
الشرعيه وهي اكبر مصادر تمويل
مجنديه وبالتالي يسعى تدريجيا الى ان يعمل
من خلال عمليه الدمج لان تصرف الدوله
السودانيه على قوات وبدنا ان يفرط في
ثروته التي اصبحت محدوده بعد تعطل موارد
ومصادر تمويل ودخله هذه الفرضيه لها
بالاعتبار
بمعنى اذا كنت فهمت ما تذهب
سيفرض واقعا جديدا ينتج وضعا يعني ربما
مختلف يتجاوز كل الاليات كل العمليات
السياسيه السابقه في السودان
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد وهنالك طرف بالتاكيد
يجلس بعيدا هنالك خلف الستاره والظفاريات
وظف هذه الكارثه للاستفاده منها وهو اعاده
انتاج نفسه من المشهد من خلال الفوضى
الخلاقه التي وصفت البندقيه كاليه رئيسيه
لايجاده في المشهد وهم فنون النظام البائد
بالتاكيد
هذا هذا الامر متى سينتج يعني مثل هذا
السيناري ومتى سيظهر نتحدث عن ساعات يمكن
من خلالها تفوق طرف على الطرف ايام قد
تاخذ هذه المعركه هذه الحرب او اكثر من
ذلك
حرب حرب المدن حرب المدن بالتاكيد تستهلك
زمنا طويلا ليست مثل المناطق المكشوفه
ربما السيد الفريق يدرك هذا الامر حرب
المدن حيث ان كل الحركات المسلحه وكلهم
يحملون السلاح بما في ذلك القوات النظاميه
تعاملهم مع المواطن السوداني باعتباره
دروع بشريه لذا الان يطلقون الرصاص
والهونات والقذائف دون ان يعتبروا
لارواحنا اوحيواتنا او ينظر اليها كلهم
يريد ان يحكم على حساب دمائنا يمارس نفوذه
وباعتبارنا كرتا للضغط او موقفا لتحسين او
شرطا لتحسين موقفه التفاوضي ليس الا لا
يعتني لا يحفلون بنا بدليل المواقع
المعسكرات المنتشره بدليل اصوات الرصاصه
التي تقف في الشوارع الرئيسيه وحساسه داخل
الخرطوم مكان اقتصاص سكاني كل ذلك يشير
بوضوح الى العقليه التي تدل المشهد
السياسي في السودان وفي يدها السلاح ولاي
هوان ذهب اليه السودان في هذا التوقيت
عليه كما قلت لك ان الذي يحكم مدى طول
العمليه العمليه العسكريه وانتصار طرف على
اخر ومدى تحقيق نجاح والاستهلاك الزمني
يتوقف على مدى تحقيق الهدف السياسي من
وراءه اذا ظل الطرف الثالث حقق نتيجته في
اعاده انتاج نفسه في المشهد من خلال اعاده
انتاج النظام البائد تحقق هذا ربما تنتهي
المعركه الان اذا نجح المكون العسكري في
ابعاد شبح عوده الحكم المدني والضغط عليه
من اجل اعاده الحكم المدني في السودان
ربما ينتهي المعركه الان كل ذلك يتوقف على
حكم بتحقيق
المؤكد والمؤكد تماما ان قوات الدعم
السريع لن تعود كما كانت ولكن التفاوض
سيعيد بقائدها الى واجهه السلطه في الوقت
الذي تخلص فيه كما قلت لكم عبر الدم او
عبر المعركه هذه التي لم يصرف عليها مره
اخرى
لك سيد عمرو شعبان ايضا من الخرطوم ينضم
الينا الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي الفريق
الدكتور جلال
مرحبا بك القتال تتصاعد في الساعات
القليله الماضيه في ارجاء متفرقه من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حديث كذلك عن
تص اعد المواجهات والعمليات القتاليه ايضا
في مروي في محيط القاعده الجويه هناك
ويتم استخدام مختلف انواع الاسلحه في هذه
المواجهات الى اين تتجه الامور عسكريه
الان في العاصمه الخرطوم برايك
الاتصال بالفريق الدكتور جلال
ربما نعود اليه في ثنايا هذه التغطيه
استاذ احمد
يعني
انتاج وضع جديد ربما هناك من يراقب المشهد
من بعيد وهو المحرك لما يحدث بشكل مباشر
او غير مباشر ويتحدث
السيد قبل قليل عن فلول سيد عمروش لنظام
السابق نظام البشير
ربما يعاد منها هذا المشهد انتاج كما ذكر
عمرو هذه نظره لذلك قلنا
ونؤكد وكل حزب المؤتمر السوداني كل
الاحزاب السودانيه حدثها بهذا المذهب وحزب
الامه انه لابد من الالتزام واظهار
الالتزام العميق بالعمليه السياسيه
المدنيه الجاريه الان بما فيها الاتفاق
الاطاري والاتفاق السياسي الناجم عنه وانه
في النهايه الجيش مؤسسه دوله وبذلك نحن
سنضرب يعني زي ما بيقولوا هدفين بحجر واحد
اللي هو انك
يعني تطرح ثقه ثقه الناس فيك كمؤسسات قوى
الحريه والتغيير وغيرها انك ملتزم قوه
الحريه والتغيير
هنالك
التعقيد تعقيد التخلف وتعقيد العمليه
السياسيه الهوجاء في السودان نجم عنه انه
في تحالفات قامت في الفتره الاخيره هنالك
من يراها يعني مثلا في اتهامات من الجيش
وحلفاءه ما يحدث يعني بين الدعم السريع
والقوه الحريه والحريه قحط وهم يرفضون ذلك
يقولون انه هذه تحالفات
مفاهيميه حول المستقبل السودان
اظهار الدعم السريع انه انت الى اين تذهب
يعني هل القوه الحريه والتغيير هي متحالفه
مع مع
مراقبه
انا ما اود التاكيد عليه فقط انه ما يحدث
الان
ربما تكون نذر اما لاستقرار يعني ونبدا
بعده عمليه سياسيه جاده او
نذر لتفجير الوضع لذلك الوضع برد لك حساس
جدا من حيث نقول الجيش انه لا بد يؤكد
التزامه ولا يذهب في الاتهامات الجزاء
فانه او من يناصرون الجيش لانه صراحه
الجيش لم يتهم احد الجيش في المعركه هذه
لغايه هذه اللحظه مؤسسه قوميه كل الناس
تقف معاه لانها هي مؤسسه قوميه لانها هي
شرط بقايا الدوله لذلك الجيش نعم نحن
ذاهبون طمانه القوى السياسيه
جميعا اننا ان هذا البلد ذاهب الى
الانتقال وذاهب الى تطبيق الاتفاق الاطاري
الذي يسمح بان يكون هنالك حكومه وحكومه
مدنيه كامله بكل صلاحياته
الحريه والتغيير وغيرها ترى ان حميتي
وقوات الدعم السريع حليف لها في اي
استحقاق سياسي قادم ضمن وان حميتي هو يذهب
في في اطار توقيع الاطار السياسي والتحول
الديمقراطي المدني
بالموافقه على الدمج السريعه الامر الذي
يرفضه البرهان والجيش كما يثار وكما يقال
الان او كما يرون يعني بذلك في ابطاء هذا
الاطار في اطار هذا الواقع اليوم الذي
نشاهد وهو واقع معقد وشاهد كما قلت لكن له
تبعته الخطيره على مستقبل السودان الامور
الى اين تتجه فعليا استاذ احمد الى انقسام
الى حرب اهليه يمكن ان نشاهد يعني معسكرين
او اكثر تتصارع فيما بينها ويدخل فيها حتى
الشعب السوداني يتورط فيها تعرف خالد عام
1898 عندما المهديه الثوره المهديه عندما
انتصرت 1885 بقياده الامام احمد احمد
المهدي على اتراك بعض الانجليز وقامت
الدوله السودانيه الذي قسم
ظهر اول دوله سودانيه في التاريخ الحديث
انه الجهويه والتكوين الجهوي اليوم حزب
الامه القومي بقياده
السيد
يعني رجل عظيم
وعنده عقلانيه واسعه انا بتكلم عن الحزب
في وقتها او عن الكيان والوقتها انه هذه
الجهويه وهذه العنصريه
حددت وادت الى يعني من الاسباب الرئيسيه
اللي اسقطت الدوله المهديه اليوم انا بقول
الجيش السوداني هو عماد هذه الدوله
لكن على قيادته مشكوره ومقدر لها في هذه
الظروف الصعبه ان تكون ملتزمه بالتحول
المدني الديمقراطي لانه اذا اردنا هزيمه
يعني مش
للتمرد بنقول للعنف الذي يسود هزيمه للعنف
وعدت استقرار لا بد ان نظمن السياسيين
لابد ان لا نتخذهم يعني
مكان نزجي فيه يعني السيء من القول والسيء
من الوصف لا قوه الحريه والتغيير بكل
اطيافها وخصوصا المجلس المركزي وقوه وطنيه
تحالفت مع حمايه لم تتحالف معه عند موقف
قياسي محدد يجب انه نلتزم به وهو الانحياز
لعمليه الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي
والاتفاق الاطار سيجعل الشعب السوداني كله
معك كمؤسسه من مؤسسه الدوله جيش السودان
عد الى سلم الهرش مراسلنا من الخرطوم ضعنا
في اخر المستجدات سالم اذا كان هناك من
جديد
نعم ليس هناك من جديد واضح على بعض الهدوء
النسبي الان في اطراف واسعه من منطقه بحري
التي كانت
تشهد اشتباكات عريفه جدا في الساعه
الماضيه الان هناك هدوء نسبي الى حد ما في
الاحوال
توقف اطلاق النار توقف هذا القنابل وسماع
عدوي الرصاص والانفجارات المتكرره عطفا
ايضا على التصريحات التي وردت كانت هناك
تصريحات للقائد قوات الدعم السريع تحدث عن
انه ليس لديه عداء مع الجيش السوداني وانه
يدعو شرفاء القوات المسلحه للانضمام لخيار
الشعب وليس القوات الدعم السريع وايضا
اوضح انه مضطروا للدخول في هذه الحرب
مجبرين وايضا تحدث على ان هناك من يقف
وراء هذه الازمه وهو السبب في هذا
الاعتداء بحسب وصفه الجيش السوداني في
المقابل ايضا تحدث على انها هذه القوه
متفلته خارجه عن القانون
وانها اصبحت عدوه مهمه حقيقي للامن الوطني
السوداني لذلك كان لابد من التعامل معها
بحسم هذا بحسب وصف الجيش السوداني
شكرا لك سالم الهاشمي الخرطوم
هل احراق الطائره المدنيه السعوديه في
مطار الخرطوم دلالات في سياق هذه المعارك
والاشتباكات لا يوجد لانه في كم طائره
اصيبت عندما اندلعت المعارك في الاول
الامر وكما اوضحت مطار الخرطوم من طاقته
كلها كانت مقسمه بين ثلاثه قوه اللي هي
الامن والجيش ودعم السريع دعم السريع وجهه
نفسه في كل مكان فعندما بدات المعارك كانت
اطلاق النار والقذائف وكذا كان عشوائي
السعوديه يعني كدابه هاينا في السودان
يعني في منطقه
كل الناس يعني
كقوه اقليميه اولى في المنطقه دائما
انحرصت على علاقات مع كل الاطراف يعني
يحفظ مصحه السودان وانا بس كنت اود ان
اشير انه في صور كثيره دلوقتي بنراها في
العربيه وكذا لشوارع رئيسيه في الخرطوم
انه الدبابات الجيش متحركه والهدوء يعني
ايوه الدخان ينطلق من بعض المناطق لكن دي
بتظهر ده في قلب الخرطوم ده شارع ما يسمى
بشارع شارع الحريه وشارع السيد عبد الرحمن
المهدي
والمنطقه هذه قريبه من مش بعيده من القصر
الجمهوري فاذا يعني كما قال سالم
زميلنا سالم لانه هو موجود في الخرطوم
بحري احيانا نقولها الخرطوم
بحري هو موجود في الخرطوم بحري الا ايضا
دي منطقه طرفيه تعتبر لا بد من يعني من
منطقه محدده يعني
انت لابد الخرطوم ام درمان ام درمان تاخذك
الى الشمال الخرطوم بحري تاخذك الى الشمال
الشرقي
فانه هذه المناطق عندما تهدا فيها
المعركه بيكون واضح انه هنالك فعلا
الدوله بواسطه مؤسسه الجيش بدات هذه
الصوره ايضا استاذ احمد
مطار الخرطوم طائره خاصه تابع الامم
المتحده
مدمره في مطار الخرطوم بعرف ان لديك
الكثير من الاتصالات الان لكن انا اريد ان
اسالك عن مشهد ربما الذهب اليه البعض وكان
ربما يلمح اليه السيد عمرو يعني قبل قليل
الان الجيش يصف ميليشيا او قوات الدعم
السريع يصفها
ويصفها بمليشيا الغدر والخيانه ونفس
تقريبا الاطار في الاتهامات يوجهها كذلك
حميتي للجيش للبرهان ماذا اذا تدخلت الان
اطراف او هل الامر وصل بالفعل لقطيعه بين
الاثنين ونقطه اللاعب والحرب المباشره
بينهما ام ان المشهد سيكون قابل لكل ما
نراه دائما يعني في المشهد السياسي ان
تدعو تعود الصوره الى السلام والاحضان
وغيرها قابل بشرط يعني حتى انه ما نكرر
كما يقولون المثقفون ننتج الازم من جديد
لا هي المساله واضحه انه لا يوجد بلد يجب
ان تكون فيه كيانات عسكريه تتبع
الاوامر او تنتهي باسلوب
منفصله داخل الدوله لانك انت هذا خلاص
هيخلق دوله داخل الدوله والنتيجه الحتيه
للفوضى اللي كانت موجوده بوجود هذه القوه
تحت امره امره خارج امره الدوله انه ما
نشهد اليوم من عذابات جديده على الشعب
السوداني انه في النهايه يجب ان يرعوا كل
انسان يعني بيفكر في مستقبل السودان انه
ما في حل بوجود القوى العسكريه يعني ما
يعني
اقول انه من المنطق من العقلانيه انه ما
نبقى تاني نقول نتكلم كانه حركه مسلحه
نريد ان ننجز معها سلاما لانه الحركات
المسلحه دلوقتي ما فيش شيء اسمه قوات دعم
سريعه لن يكون هنالك يعني نهايه هذا الوضع
اذا لم ينتهي كذلك انا لا اتحدث هل هذا
الوضع الذي ذهبت اليه يمكن ان يطمئن القوى
المدنيه في السودان اطمئنه كبيره لانه انت
في النهايه
الجيش الجيش هذا يحكم السودان منذ
استقلاله عام 1956 في الاول الجيش هو
المعرقل
للانتقال السياسي الديمقراطي المدني هنالك
اتهام للجيش بذلك لكن خالد في نهايه
المطاف هذا الجيش يعني عنده مشكلاته يعني
السودان اليوم ليس بلدا يعني بلد يعاني في
مناحي كثيره بسبب المعاناه هذه جزء منها
كبير انه الحكم العسكري اللي استمر حكم
البشير الثلاثين سنه وحكم جعفر النميري
سته عشر عاما وقبل حكم
الفريق ابراهيم عبود من
58 الى 64 كل هذه زادت اضعفت السودان
وجعلته غير قادر على انه
ينطلق او
يعني
يستخدم موارده في انه يحسن من مستوى اهله
وكذا واضح اريد فقط ان اشير في نهايه هذه
الساعه الى تصريح وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الذي يحث جميع الجهات على وقف العنف بشكل
فوري وعلى تجنب المزيد من التصعيد وتعبئه
القوات وادعى جميع الجهات في السودان
لمواصله المحادثات لحل القضايا العالقه
واشار الى ان الوزاره على الاتصال بفريق
السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم مؤكدا بان
كل الطاقم هناك بامل
مستمرون في تغطيه على راس الساعه ستكون
معكم الزميله ميسون عزل الى اللقاء
ات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات